I had a limited amount of suffering yeah
okay I was tortured and so on many
people suffered far worse than me the
Archbishop of Canterbury's special envoy
Terry Waite hasn't been seen for more
than 24 hours fears are growing that he
may be held against his will in West
Beirut where he's been trying to
negotiate the release of more hostages I
had nothing I never saw the Sun or the
sky or the felt the wind on my face
that's an extreme situation but from
extreme situations you can take
something that is applicable to normal
life initially I was kept underground in
a cell and then later on in bombed out
buildings I slept on the floor and had
nothing and I just had to say how am I
going to utilize this time what am I
going to do
I'm not a short poem about anger because
I was angry at times I had to learn how
to master anger and the short poem reads
anger is like a consuming fire seeking
all whom he may devour do not extinguish
the flames totally but calm yourself by
the gentle glow of the embers what I was
really saying is that if I allow my
understandable anger to get the better
of me
it will destroy me and it's a natural
human force we all have it you can't
litter eight it totally but take that
force and utilize it constructively I
used to say to myself although we are in
restricted and limiting circumstances
and you have no idea whether you're
going to be out tomorrow whether you got
to be out in five years whether you're
going to die in this place remember one
thing this is your life now not tomorrow
not yesterday now and in this moment
don't be defeated there's no reason to
feel sorry for yourself
[Music]
after 1763 days in Chains it's an
overwhelming experience to come back and
receive your greetings
I thought those years in captivity were
totally wasted at the time but looking
back they weren't because I was forced
there to use my imagination I was forced
I wrote my first book in my head the
brain is like a muscle you use it or you
lose it today it's a great regret to be
that the arts music literature poetry
the seen as not being really necessary
because at times of life you need to
have in your mind something that you can
draw on something that you can refer to
something that will fill out your life
so many people are suffering from mental
illness from strain from stress from
having so much pressure faced off or
forced on them somehow we need today
more than ever this ability to be at
peace with ourselves within
I'm not sure whether ever one really
reaches a state of complete happiness
it's an elusive term really I suppose
all I can strive for is to have a
greater degree of inner contentment
which is in the fact part of the road
towards happiness